good afternoon and welcome back to
downing street for today's coronavirus
briefing and i'm joined by
professor jonathan van tam the deputy
chief medical officer
and dr susan hopkins the medical
director of public health england and
nhs tests and trace and before i
share some news on our vaccination
program i'd just like to update you on
the latest coronavirus data
if we could have the first slide please
the data show
that we are moving in the right
direction i think that's the third slide
if i could have the first slide that
would be
great which has the office for national
statistics data on it
um so the um
no we'll try to get the slide up but in
the meantime
what the slide shows is that the number
of cases
is now down to one in every
145 people and that the rate of decline
is continuing but actually the pace of
it
is slowing the
rate of hospital admissions
shows a fall of 40 percent over the past
fortnight
but there are still 15
485 people in hospital and that's far
too high
the number of deaths have more than
halved in the last fortnight
but 380 deaths were reported each day on
average over the last week
and that is far too high
the good news is that the link
from cases to hospitalizations and
deaths
which has had a grim inevitability
throughout
2020 that link is now breaking
thanks to the vaccination program and
we've now been able to get the slide up
and this demonstrates as you can see
that there's been a fall in the number
of cases
another fall but that the speed of that
fall
is slowing slightly
this fact and the fact that
the pressure on the nhs has lifted
somewhat
means that the uk chief medical officers
have agreed
that the uk alert level has been moved
down from level five to level four
which is of course great news but level
four
still means that there is significant
pressure on the nhs
the number of cases is now falling
by only 15
a week in some areas of the country
that has flattened entirely and
one in five local authority areas
has seen a rise in cases in the last
week
i'm going to ask professor van tam to
set out more details of this
and the geography in a moment
but i just want to say this about the
figures
this stark picture
shows that this isn't over yet the
stay-at-home rules
are still in place for a reason every
action that you take
every time you put your mask on every
time you stay at home
you are playing your part this is on all
of us
to keep this under control this is still
a deadly virus
we will get through this but we have to
stick at it
we must all remain vigilant
and that brings me to the vaccination
program
because while the vaccination program is
rolling out at the pace of one of the
fastest in the world
we're not there yet we can all take
comfort
that through science we have found a
solution we've got a route
out and we will gradually be able to
replace
the protection that is there in the
restrictions
with protection that comes from the
vaccine and that is very good news
i'm delighted to be able to tell you
that as of this morning
19 million people in this country have
had the vaccine
that's 35 of all adults across the uk
that also includes over half a million
doses
that were given yesterday and
it's easy for us to get used to these
very large numbers
but that is 19 million people who are
now starting to get the protection that
we
know comes from this jab and we know
that the jabs are saving lives right now
across this country and of course the
program is expanding all the time
this week we're bringing 10 more major
vaccination centers on stream including
town gate theatre in basildon and
reading football club
and i thank everybody who's continuing
this expansion of the vaccination
rollout
and these join our network across the
country in
cinemas and cathedrals in mosques and
museums
and so many other places that have been
converted from whatever they
do normally into these life-saving
centers
right in the heart of our communities
and we've seen this incredible
enthusiasm about
coming forwards too as my colleague
derek grieve who heads up
scotland's rollout told her majesty the
queen
he'd like to bottle the community spirit
that we've seen i think we all feel that
and we can see it in the vaccination
program
and i'm very pleased to be able to tell
you that today's
data from the office for national
statistics show
94 of adults saying they've either
received the jab
or they intend to do so that is
staggering
it's really really good news that there
is so much enthusiasm for this jab
and it's testament to colleagues who've
worked so hard to build the
confidence in the jab and make it as
accessible
as possible to people which is what
we're constantly striving to do
i'd like to give a shout out to fazana
hussein
who is a gp in east london who's been
personally calling
each of her priority patients giving
information about the vaccine and urging
them to
to come forward and getting get jabbed i
also want to thank the whole team in
coventry and warwickshire
who have delivered the highest uptake in
the whole country
giving first doses to over 95 percent of
the over 65s
in their area thank you it's an
absolutely spectacular effort
this work is so important and it's
important
because the fight back against this
disease rests with
every single one of us and the more
people who are protected
the safer we'll all be so if you get the
call please come forward
to protect yourself and to protect those
around you
now throughout our vaccination program
we've focused on protecting those at
greatest clinical need and this is the
final thing i want to turn to
we offered a vaccine for instance to
everybody in the top four priority
groups
by the 50th of february and our current
target
is to get a first dose offered to
everybody in the top
nine priority groups by the 15th
of april that's everybody who's over 50
or part of an at-risk group earlier this
month i asked the clinicians at the jcvi
to set out
what is the best order to tackle vaccine
to offer
vaccinations for the under 50s
i asked them to make this assessment
based on how we can save
the most lives and prevent the most
hospitalizations earlier today
they published their interim
recommendations
next slide please the jcvi's clinical
advice
is that in order to save most lives
once we've offered the vaccine to
priority groups one to nine
we should take an age-based approach
and invite people to come forward in
three further stages
first people age between 40 and 49 years
old
they will be group 10 then those
30 to 39 and then those who are 18
to 29 who will become group 12.
this is the fastest and simplest way to
roll out the jab
our moral duty is to put saving
lives first and that's what we've done
so i can confirm
that we will follow this clinical advice
we will get
jabs into arms as quickly as we can
in the clinically recommended order and
once we've met the target by the 15th of
april
we'll move on to these priority groups
10 11
and 12. i'm sure that we all agree
that the best approach is the one that
saves the most
lives so that's what we're going to do
together
and while we make this great progress on
vaccines
with one of the fastest rollouts in the
world we've although
still got to hold our nerve and do our
bit it's on
all of us still to stay at home
to protect the nhs and save lives
thank you very much i now want to hand
over to professor
van tam to go through those data in more
detail
thank you secretary of state um i'm
afraid i'm going to show you a couple of
um quite sobering slides now and
i'll explain why as we go through first
slide please
so this is a uk map of
case rates and you can see it's a
heat distribution from the darkest
blue at two hundred and fifty
thousand 250 cases uh per 100 000
population per week
through to the lightest colors where
we're getting below
50 cases per hundred thousand per week
and what you can see on this slide is
that
there are still quite a few areas of the
uk
that are burning quite hot
and you can see that concentration
in the midlands and extending from the
east
to the west coast in a broad diagonal
belt you can also see some further hot
spots
in scotland and northern ireland
so this is the first slide i wanted to
show you that
although it is generally good news i'm
afraid
it is better news in some places than it
is in others
and this is not a battle that we have
won yet
next slide please
at least as importantly as the
rates of disease are the rates of
change of disease and these are seven
day
rates of change through the
um across the uk again showing
colors from white through to dark purple
where the rate of cases has
increased in the last seven days
through to from white down to dark
green areas where the rate
of change has decreased and
you can see quite clearly if you look
for the purple
and the dark purple spots i'm afraid
there are quite a few of them
and that does show that in some parts of
the uk
case rates are changing albeit
slowly but in the wrong direction this
is not
a good sign and reinforces the fact that
i'm afraid this battle at the moment um
is is not won thank you
now i'll just continue if i may
secretary state absolutely with a few
further remarks that relate to the
slides
i've shown you as you heard from
secretary of state we have now completed
19 million first doses of vaccine
we've given those first doses very
successfully to cohorts
priority cohorts one to four and we're
moving at some speed
through cohorts five to six but these
are first doses
people do need a second dose and
given that the totality of the cohorts
one to nine the priority cohorts
is about 30 million people each of whom
need
two doses of vaccine by my rough
calculations
there are something like 40 million
doses still to be given
so much as it's encouraging
and much as i am really very upbeat
about vaccines
and how they are going to change how we
live and and what the disease is like
between now and the summer
there is a long way to go and
my inbox in the in the last week
has been um besieged with
people writing in saying i've had the
vaccine
essentially can i now start to break the
rules
can i go and see my grandchildren can i
do x y and z
and and the answer to that is no
we are not yet collectively as a country
in the right place and all the patients
that i vaccinate
and they'll know it if they're listening
on the tv i say to them and remember all
the rules
still apply to all of you and all of us
until um we're in a much safer place it
doesn't change
because you've had your first dose of
vaccine and so
you know please don't be tempted to
think
uh well one home visit might be all
right now weather's getting better
going to be a nice weekend one small
gathering
in your house don't really matter i'm
afraid it does and
the the data on the slides speak for
themselves
so my kind of key message tonight is
look this is all going very well
but there are some worry signs that
people are
relaxing taking their foot off the brake
at exactly the wrong time it's a bit
like being three nil up in a game
and thinking well we can't possibly lose
this now but how many times have you
seen the other side take it four
three do not wreck this now
it is too early to relax just
continue to maintain discipline and hang
on just a few more months
do not wreck this now we are so close
thank you secretary of state thank you
uh
professor van tam and um for that
clear if sobering assessment we're
nearly there
let's not blow it the first question is
from
um emma from worthing what plan do you
have for supporting university students
through your roadmap out of lockdown
thanks very much emma it's an incredibly
important question
and the roadmap sets out some of the
details in terms of the
return of universities to something more
like a normal
university experience it the answer to
your question depends on the course that
you're studying
and therefore how much you need to be
physically present there's some courses
that have been running
throughout including with uh
of course with covid secure arrangements
where people need to be in a
in a lab or a medic medical school for
example
and then there's others um and
especially art subjects
where it is easier to to learn and to
have that over
zoom or video conferencing and so
it there is quite a lot of detail here
and the department for education have
put out
a significant amount of guidance but of
course
as with everything else on the roadmap
um we've set out the indicative dates
but also we've got to be vigilant on the
data
according to the four tests that the
prime minister set out final point
we have today set out the order in which
we're going to
vaccinate people and people who are
between 18 and 29 will come in group
12 so it is incredibly important for you
to get your jab
when it's your turn as well because that
will help not only to protect you
but to protect everybody around you as
well thanks emma next question
hannah from belfast
why has the government removed guidance
from last summer allowing couples in
established relationships not to
socially distance from each other
and what would stop support bubbles
being extended to allow couples to see
each other again without limits on
social contact
well thanks hannah the we took the
we made the change that we did um to
because as we went into the lockdown
over the
uh autumn uh in november and then again
at the start of uh january we wanted to
make sure
that we did everything we possibly could
to stop this from spreading
um and i'm absolutely um sure
that the actions that everybody has
taken and the sacrifices that people
have made
have had that very very positive impact
um we do look of course at the
support bubbles we hold these uh all
these rules under review
and but the purpose of the support
bubbles is so that people living on
their own
can socialize because we know just how
difficult it is to live on your own
uh if you have no contact at all so
that's the reason for
for that support bubble um thanks very
much
hannah next question is from hugh pym at
the bbc
thank you very much secretary of state
the government says it's prioritizing
education in the weeks ahead what do you
say to
teachers who argue that giving them
priority for the vaccine
could help reduce absences and
disruption in classrooms
well thanks hugh the first thing i'd say
is that
we looked at all of these different
considerations and the jcvi
looked at all these different questions
including of course the prioritization
according to different
to different jobs that people have and
but the overall view that we came to
was that the right thing to do the moral
thing to do
is to make sure that we save the most
lives
and the jcvi looked at the clinical
evidence
and also the evidence of how quickly
operationally we can jab everybody
and that means that the clinical
guidance from
the jcvi is very clear that we should
continue through the age
range and we also know from the data
that thankfully teachers are no more
likely to catch covert
than any other member of the population
who goes to work
and so trying to come up with a scheme
which prioritizes one professional group
over another
would have been well would have been
complicated
complicated to put in place and wouldn't
have done what we asked the jcvi to do
which i think is the right thing
which is to make sure that we minimize
the amount of
people who die by using the by using the
vaccine
i don't know whether jvt you've got more
details on this
thanks secretary straight here i could
just add a little bit more
color for you i suppose to say that the
ons data on the occupations with the
highest
rates of death begin with restaurant and
catering establishment managers and
proprietors
follow on to metal working and machine
operatives
food drink and tobacco process
operatives chefs
taxi and cab drivers i won't go on but
um all of those death rates in the
groups i mentioned
are in in excess of uh 100
deaths per 100 000
for males if you look at teachers and
the ons has now
um assembled some data on teachers for
the period 9th of march last year to the
28th of december the figures for
male teachers the figure is 18.4
per 100 000 for mortality
and that compares with an age average
for a comparable age
of 31.4 so if our objective
is to save lives and reduced
hospitalizations
then we have to start in a logical place
and if our objective is to prioritize by
age
we would have to by occupation we would
also have to start in a logical place
and you can see that is going to be very
difficult because of the multiplicity
of occupations that would need to be
called forwards
and doing that is going to damage the
pace
of the vaccine roll out so much and the
big win
actually is in speed so the kind of
message is really
when we're getting down into the into
the
phase two of the vaccine campaigns
it's more important
to be in the queue worry less about
exactly where you are in the queue but
be reassured that the queue is moving
really fast and that you're going to get
to the front of the queue
because it's moving fast and that's
really
um i think the analogy that i i want to
kind of paint
for you that being in the queue is more
important
than where you are in it and then making
that queue move really fast is
the key thank you secretary thanks very
much hugh
next question is from liz bates at
channel 4
yes thank you so as you just set out um
quite starkly
different areas have very different
rates of infection it seems that would
suggest
that as we come out of national lockdown
we might see the return of local
lockdowns is that going to happen um
or is that something that you want to
avoid and can i also ask
jvt if we can have a bit more detail um
on what's behind those
regional differences uh thanks very much
liz
so we want to we propose to come
out of the uh national lockdown all
together
um these regional disparities are
smaller than we saw
in the autumn and we don't rule out
taking
local action in an individual area if we
see a spike and
i'll ask dr hopkins to say a bit more
about that
um but the goal is for us all to come
out
together and what i want to stress
is that these data show how important it
is that we still stick at it
that this isn't over yet and the fact
that you know
one in five local authority areas across
the country
has seen cases rise in the last week
demonstrates that we
all need to uh to stick to those rules
and to do everything we can
to keep this pandemic under control um
i'll ask dr hopkins to comment on that
and put more
detail on and then jvt to answer your
second question
thank you so i think we are looking at
into detail at the
differences in the regions some of the
differences that we can see relates to
the occupations and workplaces that
occur
and as you know we have increased
workplace testing with lateral flow
devices
i think it's really important that
people come forward for testing in the
next four weeks
so that gives us the opportunity to find
those hidden cases in communities
and to allow the case rates to come down
over the next four week period
it we still have plenty of time in this
time of national restrictions
to reduce the case rates across the
country we'll also be working very
closely with directors of public health
and our regional health protection teams
to ensure that we take local action
right now so we're not waiting for four
weeks time
to see what happens then and that's
happening across the country right now
with engaged teams
looking at how we can find cases um
contact trace in those areas and support
people in isolation
thanks very much and jvt nothing to add
secretary of state thank you
thank you liz thank you uh next question
is charlotte ivers
from talk radio thank you mr hancock
we've had
lots of calls from listeners this week
who are raring to go to get their
vaccines
but they're also a bit concerned and
confused by the government's policy on
vaccine passports are you able to give
them a commitment today that they will
never need to show
a vaccine passport to get into the pub
board for a football match
uh thanks very much well look this is an
incredibly important subject
we know that there's some areas where
certification is going to be needed
for instance if a if a government of
another country
says that you need to show that you've
had a covid vaccine
obviously we then want to be able to
[Music]
help people enable people to be able to
show that
certificate um but the the the wider
questions have all been
um put into a review uh that as you know
michael gove is leading um and i think
it's best to
allow that review to take evidence to
consider all of the broad range of
issues
and and then come to its conclusion i'm
sorry i'm not going to be more specific
than that
i don't want to fetter the discretion of
the of the review and i think it's uh
it's right that we take our time to
think about this thanks very much
and next question is jonathan riley from
the sun
hi good afternoon um to professor van
tam
there are reports today that uh school
children as young as
five are being told to wear masks in
classrooms
should teachers really be doing this and
is it really a necessity to
stop the spread of covid and to
secretary of state
the uh kobe crisis has seen an
outpouring of community spirit and
volunteerism
including of course the sun's jabs army
campaign
do you think these volunteers should be
recognized in some way and are you going
to
or are there any plans to try and use
this this bank of volunteers
after the pandemic to help our nhs
yes two great questions um the jabs army
marches on
and they're doing an amazing job in
helping everybody to get the vaccines
and
the voluntary effort around the vaccine
rollout has been unbelievably
brilliant the number of people who've
come forward
the enthusiasm that's shown and i'm very
grateful to everybody who's given up
their
time we are looking at a
system of nhs reserves and the idea is
that you have people who are
committed to supporting the nhs through
voluntary
action through who have the training for
instance and are on a specific reserves
program
and we're piloting that right now but
that's exactly the sort of thing that
the
jabs army might might might be called
upon to do
in the future in a broader sense because
we've just seen the
unbelievable support that volunteers can
give to the nhs
when there's a big job to do and i'll
ask dr hopkins to
uh to respond to your first question
about masks amongst children thank you
so i think the important thing to
say is that we've looked and reviewed
the data and the evidence on this
school children have the lower amount of
infection especially primary school
children
and in looking at it we've talked to
educationalists public health and
clinical specialists
and the consensus view is very strongly
to not advise
school children a primary school age to
wear face coverings
this for two reasons one is that they
can have difficulties wearing them and
keeping them on all day
and the second part of that is that it's
really important that they can see
facial expressions
in order to develop their communications
and language skills
schools have done a lot of delivered a
lot of measures to reduce the risk in
schools
and additional plans to test our
families of primary school children will
also be in place as schools go back
and therefore the strong recommendation
is for primary school children not to
wear masks
thanks very much anything to add jvt
my perspective on this is more parental
than it is um
technical and that is to say i just find
it quite a
um daunting proposition to try and keep
um
face masks on 35 year olds in the same
room
you know i just think you should be
concentrating on the teaching
thanks very much indeed um the next
question is from ned simons at the
huffington post
uh thank you health secretary um
official figures show there are over
three and a half million nhs sick days
in england due to mental ill health
between march and october last year
but it's been reported that healthcare
workers won't get a pay rise in the
budget
um what were you going to do to support
nhs staff
other than asking the public to clap and
dr hopkins and professor van tam if i
may um last year's eat out to help out
scheme was associated with an increase
in transmission
would you be comfortable with it
returning uh this spring and summer
so on the support for the nhs staff this
is incredibly
important question and there's a huge
amount of support being put in place
to ensure that staff especially those
who've had
a really tough time in this
second wave of the of the pandemic
and who've had a tough time in many
cases throughout the last year
to ensure that nhs staff get the r
r that they need and of course
employment in the nhs is down to the
individual trust
and there's a huge amount of work going
on to make sure that people get the
support
to deal with traumatic experiences that
they may have had
you know i've supported
in intensive care awards uh during the
pandemic
i i've seen the pressures that nhs staff
are under
i i know i i know from talking to them
um what it feels like and the pressures
that they've been under
both the constancy of the work the
enormous amount of work that's had to be
done
but also the fact that when you are
dealing with people
and the death rate is so high that has a
significant psychological impact so we
are
putting in place that support to make
sure that people
get people on who've been on the front
line in what can be traumatic
situations get the support they need the
professional support they need
um as well as the uh as the hr support
they need
in order to be able to uh uh to
to have that r r and b
uh firing on all cylinders again and uh
and and get
and have that resilience um and then
when it comes to the
uh second question uh jbt yes thanks for
the question
i mean i'm going to give quite a
clinical answer really
um when you put people together
to um eat and socialize over a meal
over a table as we all like to do
um and maybe a little drink is also
consumed at the same time and the volume
goes up in the
in in the place of course it is likely
that there will be
some transmission but really
who pays the bill or how much of the
bill you have to pay for yourself is
not a medical question and one for
politicians and in particular the
chancellor
thanks very much final question is from
jim scott at the northern echo jim
thank you here in the northeast we have
some gp surgeries having to cancel
vaccine clinics because they are not
receiving the supply
that they expected one surgery in our
region can't run clinics until march the
5th at the earliest because of lack of
supply
we have a huge review rural areas that
rely on gdp surgeries for vaccines
rather than the mass vaccination centers
used in urban areas
why are people in the north still having
to travel more than 40 miles in some
cases to get
to get their doors and is this a sign
that your vaccination strategy has been
designed for the south
uh and just one question to professor
vantam
north yorkshire police are still giving
out hundreds of fines for lockdown
breaches
as people travel to beauty spots in our
region including in some cases
more than 100 miles now that the prime
minister has set out his roadmap out of
lockdown
are you concerned people now think the
end is here and are less likely to stick
to the rules
so jim just on your first question i'll
ask dr hopkinskins to come in
but one of the brilliant things about
this vaccination program is how it has
been
equal and fair uk wide and the northeast
has done a
brilliant job in vaccinating it came out
of the blocks really fast
and has done worked absolute
wonders and i want to thank in
particular
the volunteers and the nhs staff in the
northeast who have worked so hard to get
these vaccinations
done and the there has been a
lower amount of supply across the whole
uk
in the last week or so you'll have seen
that in
the last 48 hours that has picked up
again and yesterday we did over half a
million jabs again for the first time
in over a week um so that supply is
is coming back we all know that it goes
in uh it's lumpy
it comes up and down and we're going to
have a bumper march um but i do
know that there have been some
vaccination centers that are so
efficient
they've been able to use all of their
supply and i'm very very grateful for
the work that they've done
but the good news is that these
challenges are faced
equally throughout the whole of the
uk and i get people from um brilliant
local newspapers in the south west
asking the same question as you're
asking about the about the northeast
and that gives me the impression uh that
uh the the
this challenge of the rollout is equally
balanced uh as far as i'm concerned
every single person getting their access
to their jab in the northeast
is as important as in every other part
of the country
and will make sure that the program
delivers uh according to that uh
according to those principles um and um
i uh i and and i don't know what more i
can say
about my enthusiasm for what the
northeast has done and really really
nailed it in this vaccination program so
far um susan
yeah i think that's that's exactly right
so the northeast has been achieving
over and above for what it was the rest
of the country has done it's fantastic
news
everywhere is going to get vaccine
vaccine and everywhere we'll be able to
deliver the vaccine
to all of those from one to nine over
the coming weeks
thanks very much and on your second
question uh jbt
yeah thank you yes is the answer
um i do worry that people think it's all
over
um the more they think that when it's
not
the greater the headwind they're going
to give to the vaccine program
and the more at risk will become
the um milestones set
on the road map and you know it's just a
collective effort
it is actually up to us whether
we can hold our nerve and see this
through properly
to the end of the road map or
whether we're going to kind of you know
fall at the last furlough
thanks very much and thank you all for
joining the
uh the daily briefing today once again
i'm going to end
um with um where i ended the opening
which is to say that
this is on all of us of course it's on
us at the podium
to do our duty and play our part but
it's on
you as well every single person needs to
keep sticking to those rules
stay at home protect the nhs and save
lives
we're making great strides but we're not
there yet
thank you very much indeed